they've called for a medical consult and
Dr Mike is here to react and comment on
the declining health of the American
conservative media Mogul Logan Roy from
the show succession let's get started
and take it right from the first episode
of the first season
so nighttime Awakenings for elderly men
are one of the biggest risk factors for
an early death because of hip fractures
in the middle of the night when it's
dark you're a little woozy you don't
know what's going on a fall can happen a
hip fracture can happen and immobility
for someone of elderly age can be very
problematic when you're a mobile you
actually have higher rates of blood
clots heart disease and those things
happening in that moment as opposed to
10 years down the line
here he's exhibiting a little bit of
confusion for me as a medical provider I
start thinking of something known as AMS
altered mental status this can happen in
elderly individuals as a result of a
urinary tract infection really any
infection
look
oh
wow yeah getting old uh is tough but
after that that's how that warrants the
911 call because you don't know that AMS
is due to a urinary tract infection he
had urinary urgency and frequency and he
went or is it because he's actively
having a stroke hard to know we get that
we do and we would love to help I mean I
would love to help and help but anyone
why would I I'm giving away power why
would I do that
so
Kelly uh who's Kelly Kelly myself some
figures you should see that
everything so here we're seeing signs of
slurring of speech dad inability to find
words
full-on syncope like he could be having
a heart attack right now the first thing
I'd be doing a situation like this is
checking for a pulse because if he's
unconscious out of pulse you got to
start chest compressions
he's he is somewhat conscious so there
is no need for chest compressions at
this time protecting his Airway is of
utmost importance so making sure that if
he does vomit because a lot of times
people will develop nausea in situations
like this making sure that they don't
aspirate or choke on their own vomit
what is this part of the hospital I mean
is this the best section A lot of
patients ask questions like this is this
the best are you the best doctor that
doesn't really exist yes you want
private rooms you want to make sure that
the tendings are there but the protocols
that the hospitals have in place already
the best doesn't mean advocacy by family
is not important that's actually very
important the ICU is the ICU this is the
best place for him is this where you
would take your father I'm sorry can the
team have some space please hey hey
here's an idea why don't you worry about
the medicine not the feng shui energy
let's let the gentleman do his job it's
not the feng shui it's about the fact
that doctors nursing staff can
adequately perform their jobs when
they're distracted by family members so
yes the medication error rate goes up
when the family is in the room putting
pressure on the medical staff take me
through through what happened exactly I
don't know exactly it was weird it
happened fast we were just sitting there
talking and she had kind of started
hardballing dad and then okay brain
hammers doesn't come from some Chit Chat
they're saying brain hemorrhage which
means a brain bleed remember when
there's Strokes there's two types of
Strokes a hemorrhagic stroke where
there's some kind of blood vessel
rupture in the brain and you have
bleeding into the brain so that you're
not getting enough circulation but then
also you could have a stroke from an
ischemic component which means that
there's a blockage of blood flow like
the plumbing is blocked and you're not
getting enough circulation somebody said
that right somebody said Hemorrhage or
stroke Hemorrhage is a stroke it could
be an aneurysm an aneurysm can be a risk
factor for a stroke especially if it
ruptures a ruptured aneurysm can create
a hemorrhagic stroke so they're saying a
lot of medical words but they're not
putting them into context
foreign
getting a CAT scan here he's had a
hemorrhagic stroke a bleeding a deep
bright hemisphere that put pressure on
the thalamus and the brain stem and
that's what caused the loss of
consciousness so apparently some blood
vessel had ruptured it was bleeding
inside the brain which could be
visualized on a CAT scan and from there
you have to just work on stabilizing the
patient sometimes the Hemorrhage can be
so bad that you actually need to perform
a craniotomy where you take a piece of
the skull off of the person and you
allow the pressure to escape if you're
increasing pressure from bleeding
bleeding bleeding into an enclosed space
you could actually create like pressure
and a mass effect that is lethal the
evidence is that operating in situations
like these isn't worthwhile a lot of
times the bleeds or blockages happen in
deeper areas of the brain so they're
sort of inoperable because the amount of
risk you have going into the brain in
order to reach this can actually
outweigh the potential benefit of
stopping the bleed especially if the
bleed is already stabilized on its own
there are certain ways that they do this
through less invasive methods where they
go actually through arteries and can
actually go through let's say your
radial artery it's actually the way we
put stents into the heart when someone
is having a heart attack but this is not
available for all types of blockages
well we will carry out regular
observations and hopefully we'll see
some improvements soon
well thank you for your input but you'll
understand if we check out our options
my assistant's been in touch with Ann
Wyman at NYU and we we might move dad
there no
he stays here he gets better here moving
patients when they are in a critical or
near critical condition he's usually
never advisable because a lot of things
can go wrong during the transport and
when that happens you have way worse
outcomes even when we have a patient
that I am let's say wanting to bring
from the regular Hospital floor and I
want to bring them to the ICU for more
careful monitoring I cannot move them
until I have created a level of
stability in their own room and that's
just moving within the hospital think
about flying them Etc et cetera we'll
discuss and get back to you no
no discussion I am his next of kin I am
Miss proxy a lot of these situations
occur in hospitals where next of kin
arguments occur and I've seen really
messed up situations like this is
probably one of them but I've seen ones
where you have uh children taking
advantage of an elderly family member
because they're cashing their like
Social Security checks or they know that
if this person is to pass they would
lose some sort of benefit Financial
elder abuse is real and a lot of times
it gets exposed during situations like
this I need a piss oh
sure uh sure do you need some help or I
can reach out to
you
let's go you want to make a decision now
before or uh
what you think Logan yes or no I see
altered mental status coming back hey
are you okay you're really shivering I
think we need to get you seen by
somebody
's son anytime
Pop I mean it's full-on altered mental
status in situations like this so if
your dad is totally out of it there's no
way you can say that someone is
competent enough to make a business
decision especially that affects so many
people and I think as a publicly traded
company you have to disclose this There
are rules set forth by the SEC hey
education
shouldn't that's what happens if he
doesn't take them anytime an elderly
patient has an infection they can become
altered mental status they can develop
an altered mental status because when
there is a requirement for higher blood
flow to the infected area their stress
hormones released that essentially
creates a level of confusion because
there's not enough circulation or blood
pressure to even reach the brain Tom
what's going on what happened
short of breath and he went into the
bathroom and he was going and that was
someone heard something and he was uh we
were concerned they
are there but he's not
he's still in there did he's he's
non-responsive non-responsive on an
airplane is a serious cause for concern
they're doing chest compressions at
least they're doing chest compressions
has his heart stopped
do you guys do you have the machine uh
on board the hard thing the AED should
be on board given the fact that it's
such an expensive plane and all but the
first thing they should be doing is
rerouting the plane next they should be
checking for a pulse if he's truly
unconscious without a pulse they should
be doing chest compressions and someone
should be getting the AED okay I'm
putting you by his ear now oh my God
those are some terrible chest
compressions
not okay
not speaking dear hang up this phone
call and focus on trying to revive their
father
okay those are really bad chest
compressions remember the purpose of
doing chest compressions is to
physically move the chest down two
inches to squeeze the heart and
therefore take the blood that's within
the heart and push it throughout the
body almost like simulating a heartbeat
but when you do that you're only getting
about a 20 efficacy if you do it
perfectly when you do it like that it's
complete I'm heading to the back of the
plane is clear
and oh I hear the defibrillators that
means they have put on the AED the way
the AED works is you can put it on while
you're performing chest compressions and
then it'll say don't touch person
analyzing they'll tell you if this is a
shockable rhythm shock advised press
flashing shock button it'll say charge
shock delivered start CPR
if it's a non-shockable rhythm it'll say
non-shockable Rhythm immediately
continue doing chest compressions
for someone of his age if you're going
20 minutes with a stopped heart that is
catastrophic but that doesn't mean that
he's dead medically that means he's dead
I need my doctor and I need do they have
his doctor no did you have his doctor on
the line there is no help that his
doctor can give in a situation like this
this is a first aid land as fast as
possible to a hospital if you have
epinephrine maybe you give it in a
situation like this but I can't imagine
anyone on that flight is going to be
capable enough to do this
here are things you should never do in
the hospital especially the way that the
Roy's did it click here to check that
out and as always stay happy and healthy
foreign